In East Africa,
ivory trafficking is
probably what you might guess.
It's organized crime,
it's poachers on the ground,
corrupt governments.
Central Africa; Completely
different. It's a war zone.
These are the rangers.
These six men are dead.
They were on an anti-poaching
mission on Heban Hill in 2012
in Chad,
Zakouma National Park
when Janjaweed came in
they were in their
morning prayers
and killed them all.
This woman was attacked by
the Lord's Resistance Army
which cut her, she's had
multiple surgeries since.
Cut her ears off, her lips off,
and her nose.
This is Emmanuel de Merode.
He and his men were
Explorers of the Year here
at National Geographic.
Emmanuel runs the
park at Virunga.
The most courageous man
on the planet.
He was shot last year,
ambushed...
for his work to preserve
Virunga National Park.
Innocent,
who works with Emmanuel.
A National Geographic
Emerging Explorer.
These tusks were
seized from FDLR.
The Rwandans,
Hutus have come into
and live in Virunga National
Park and exploit that park
and have killed a number
of rangers this year.
These guys are,
a part of a force
the African Union force
dedicated to going after
Joseph Kony and the
Lord's Resistance Army.
These are anti-Lord's Army
Resistance army rangers.
This is all the more significant
because these men don't
know how to swim.
And they go out every day,
this--
This guy is a defector from
the Lord's Resistance Army.
Michael Onen, beaten by the
men who kidnapped him.
And it's all because
of those two teeth.
So, let's go after these people.
Let's be creative.
Let's move forward.
This is George Dante, one of
the world's best taxidermists.
I hired him to build me
fake elephant tusks.
Then I had an engineer
in California
build me a satellite
based GPS system.
And I laid them
inside those tusks.
That's the result, you
tell me which one's real.
We put our tusks in
Central Africa
in the black market, and we
watched them, using an iPad.
And they went to this
area of Darfur.
Called Kafia Kingi.
That's where Joseph Kony is.
And so that was the new face,
for me, of the ivory story.
The violence,
the terrorism behind ivory.
And I was excited about
telling this story
we told it as the
September cover story.
We told it as the launch, new
launch of the Explorer series
"Warlords of Ivory",
and as a result
you give the world the
opportunity to ask
"does it want this?"
"Does it want this?"
Every story is a gift.
These stories are my gift
to these animals
that can't speak
and to these men and
women who pay so much
and your gift to them can
be to share this story.